las siglas cops significan en inglés
conference of parties en español
conferencia de partes es decir los
firmantes de la convención de las
naciones unidas sobre el cambio
climático firmado en 1992 hombre de la
tierra de río entró en vigor en
1994 este texto es el principal tratado
internacional para luchar contra el
calentamiento global
la que está conformada por 196 partes
195 países más la unión europea desde
1995 se lleva a cabo una reunión mundial
de dos semanas que se realiza
sucesivamente en cada continente
y entre los participantes también se
encuentran autoridades locales y actores
de la sociedad civil o de la comunidad
científica
[Música]
durante la conferencia los países ricos
y pobres deben ponerse de acuerdo para
limitar el calentamiento global como
cada año ese es el centro del debate en
2015 al final de la cob 21 los estados
firmaron un primer acuerdo universal
sobre el clima el acuerdo de parís este
debía llevar a mantener el calentamiento
global por debajo de 2 grados incluso de
un grado y medio en relación con la era
preindustrial de aquí a 2100 pero las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
continúan en aumento según el último
informe del ipcc de agosto de 2021 la
tendencia hoy es de un calentamiento
global de 4 e incluso de 5 grados
[Música]